our smoky skies are back you can see it
smell it no surprise here we are under
an air quality advisory thank you for
joining us at five i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez it's been a very
unhealthy day especially for people who
might have breathing sensitivities so
tonight we have team coverage ted
florindo will tell us when we can expect
some relief and we start with sally
jaramillo who's been out in that haze
all day sally
brian and denise we've been dealing with
this off and on for a while now those
california wildfires are sending smoke
our way and it seems like it's been
going on all summer
murky gray skies and thick haze has been
seen throughout the valley today this
all due to the knp complex fire and the
windy fire coming from central
california kevin mcdonald with the clark
county department of sustainability says
they issued the advisory yesterday
afternoon because they saw conditions
getting worse and although we are used
to dust in the desert we don't deal with
smoke that often this time of year
wildfire season is becoming the new
normal for clark county because we are
seeing more more days with smoke
advisories than with particle pollution
and also smoke does influence ozone
formations mcdonald's says climate
change is real and some tips you are
always recommended to do under these
conditions
stay indoors limit your time outdoors
change your filters close windows and
doors exercise indoors and fuel your
tank after sunset
now out here live visibility was also
very low this morning due to these
conditions and ted we're hoping our
shifting winds will be changing all of
this activity by tomorrow
that's right sally in fact that's what's
going to happen right we were seeing the
wind speeds they were a little calm this
morning that allowed the air to get a
little more dense for that smoke but
notice the wind's now up to 17. it's a
little breezy outside that's allowing
some mixing at this hour air quality
advisories still remain in play through
this evening air quality in a moderate
category like we talked about unhealthy
though for those of you with sensitive
lungs we're talking asthma and
bronchitis so here are the weather
headlines breezy this evening what
that's going to do is clear that smoke
from the south as that cold front slices
through then after that we're going to
see cooler 80s for our daytime highs and
chilly
morning temperatures for some of you i'm
going to show you all this and more and
neighborhood by neighborhood
temperatures all coming up in your most
accurate forecast just minutes away